welcome to the final gym of the
great life jamón de morales with me
again after a few months
welcome thank you very much
I always love seeing you that the whole team
also you there in the house to
give you a look of what is going to happen
with all the artists right now this
week that we are preparing for
the grammys exactly we are ready
tell a little about all the
gifts that the artists are giving you well
first we are going to start with one of
the favorite glasses and that is that
the stars have also loved it  that they are from
turbo clicks and what I want you to see
here that is great is the technology that
has the truth that they can be bent here and
everything and they will not break they look
great on you too is that we have seen
many assets that have  arrived that
they have not just wanted more for themselves
but they have even asked me I think
that my wife because she is a mother is true that she is
not afraid for my children so they have
a line  for children also for men
and women and what they did exclusively
for the grammys I don't know if you can see
there but it says there the year of the
grammys that they are made exclusively
for us here so everyone is
one thing each person who has
come chooses  a couple are for them
but people in the house can
grab the technology from other brands and
styles too so this is also
popular this year and then we also have
you know every time we've come here
especially we're doing
mega this year every  people want to see
how they can take care of their skin better since
we are close to summer so
we have here this product from mijas
that I love because it is made from
vegetables and it is to help you absorb
everything faster so that you
can really notice the  difference in a
few weeks and not have to wait
months to see it and it is more than anything
perfect for las vegas with the dryness
and if or if we need something p  So that
our skin doesn't look all dry and
everything is perfect now a little bit about
that because
the collaboration that they are doing with
pure truth is very interesting and then fira has returned
with us and for a year what they have
done is a collaboration with  a great
thread and this one to all the different
shoes that they have to choose from are
made of material that is not at all leather
and that does not harm animals and
ask what we love every year is that
they want to show that they have a voice
It's easy for animals and it's something that
we can all do. Rules, we have to
be aware of the fruits that
we are exactly accelerating,
and speaking of whether
they also have a lot of the products they have selected
or have an
inclusive initiative for inclusion and
diversity.  A little bit about these
stockings and these flowers oh yes so the
stockings you have seen are they grab
the
prize for those who have traveled the
most the farthest  They come from
South Africa and that one, well, a man who found us
on social networks for the people who
say social networks are of use to us
, the old man couldn't be found, you know I
want to do something, this is the
number one sock sold here  in the country and
I would like to be part of it so
for that we saw how cool
this plan with business we love we are going
to support and then just like the sun these
voices that can be seen there have a
special treatment that allows them to
be preserved for up to
without having to put water or anything on it,
but what I want you to see is that they
made a little box because you can
put the jewelry there we have agro again I know
that I love what they do, well,
this city that can be put on the
red carpet then  where else can you
have your jewelry but you can have them in
pairs of luxury and also for
mothers day this is as I tell you it has
also been a super cool gift that everyone
has told us how much  they like it and the
company owns it there are two women
who own it who also likes a time gift
but well speaking of jewelry here
we also have a little more holes
tell us a little about yourself so
just as gross and as he told you
they have returned  with us and they make
a jewel that will not only look
great in the red zone but also
at home for those
special moments that you have without having to
spend
on buying a house you can see luxury
but it also looks expensive  and also the
jewel does not stain or change
color, which I love so this
is the fourth year that we have had it and we have
always
seen a few stars who have gone to
pick them up and then wear them in the area
red but in front of the second I can
feel as if it were also because
we believe that everyone sits here that
on Sunday of course of course and speaking of that
we can also dream of a little bit of a
real version of lingua and the movements
about this then this super
cool company its profile and as we have seen since we
don't have much to do right on
the regular day but we are
leading the stars by seeing bears as they
say right so for them to have the
experience if they want to play games
listening to music so it's
bringing all that to us and we also have another
company that's here called mine
that inside what has given
everyone the opportunity is that they can play
with a
virtual design to have an
experience that is timely  that as
we say in English that they stop talking
to him or sing the guitar and
eventually the artist himself if I
want to do it in an event also the same
to put it in the merval you can
as he wears
the blue head or the blues
I love I go talking  from the mere see
if we finish virtual reality because
also something for children and for
children and also for the feet it is
because we are going to talk to me because here it is for
many  I really love
that I have my other pair that they gave us
like this for five years and there are the
most comfortable customs because not just below
I think you see below it is as if it were a
technician but then from above it is like a little
jacket one  pillow that gives you a
hug your visitors that are there
especially one day later they stay they
make heels super comfortable Haiti just like
that if you want to give orders to the goal
so that they themselves play here
we have these snacks that come from
bigger crises than these  toys are
super cool they have one that I love that
is a little cube that pushes salty and
an avocado comes out a jalapeño
that I say or magar berkut so this
is for where it is not also they
liked it a lot and they have a variety of
different toys that  you can listen
to choose and then we can't
leave here without also talking about top coat
which for us is not just an
experience every time we come to las
vegas but every  p coat is now going to have two
different locations in los angeles
so they open next month
so every artist that comes is
giving them a certificate via here so
they can go play capcom on the lay
with their friends and have like a night
that  They are going to remember everything even though they
won they didn't beat us on Sunday there it
is perfect as you said something and
unforgettable mobile for a good cause
achieve diversity inclusivity and
everything something for everyone in the family something
for everyone inclusive of that also
make a bag  but super big that
is already filled with other products that
we have from the world and that
we can all give it so that, as I
said, they can feel that they are perfect winners,
thanks and thanks to you bye